hi
my name is kiana and i'm the co-founder
and cso of cadilla
and i'm also an assistant professor of
biomedical sciences at keck graduate
institute
a member of claremont colleges in this
presentation i'm going to introduce to
you
the vision of our startup cadilla bio
our platform
and our first line of products which
which are designed for crispr
quality control applications
so so biology is systems of systems
which are continuously communicating
with each other
in a dynamic fashion but for many years
in life sciences we have been
taking the snapshots of these dynamic
events
using optics to understand biology and
to identify
different pathologies to truly
understand biology
we need to understand the interplay
between these
system systems in a dynamic way
and biology is comprised of lots of
these dynamic systems
that are connected for example
nucleotides protein complexes small
molecules
enzymes cells and various tissue types
so biology is
systems of systems
so to truly understand biology you need
to take a system biology approach
we need to have an insight to multiple
analyze and multi-perspective biological
data in near real time
in near real time where we can have a
flow of information
not just a snapshot data sets um
having an insight to multi-analyte
activity in real time is the only way to
understand biology and the interplay
between these different biological
systems
which can pave the way for new
fundamental uh
discoveries in in biology
so this vision requires obtaining large
volume of data including
genomics proteomics and other type of
biological data
and sometimes in a in a personalized
fashion obtaining this
real-time multi-ohmic data using exis
existing technology like optical
platform is not possible
the wavelength of optical platforms are
limited and it's not sufficient
to look at nanoscale biological event
quantitative
multiplexing will require expensive
instrumentation if using optics
amplification and many optical labels
which is which makes the process very
very um complex
so so
we need to really have an infrastructure
where we can measure multiple different
uh
analyze at the same time and be able to
transfer this large volume of
multi-omics data
to computers so we can develop
algorithms to process them
and to unlock their immense amount of
information this is only possible
through highly scalable cost effective
electronic system
that can also be personalized and
seamlessly transfer data to computers
for analysis
and this is what cadilla does kadia is
connecting biology to computers for the
very first time
by building an infrastructure using
transistors to directly
stream uh multi-omics data to computers
in
near real-time fashion this allows a
new generation of platform to obtain new
biological
information our platform works by
utilizing
graphene-based fill detect transistors
in this transistor the conductive
graphene channel is produced between the
two terminals of the transistors namely
source and drain and the third terminal
which is the gate
terminal controls the electric field
applied to our transistors
the graphene channel is biologically
activated to specifically interact with
our target analyte
which can be a protein a dna sequence or
any biological molecule
the interaction between the target
analyze and the biology
fixated atop our graphene channel
changes the conductivity of the graphene
material
which in turn changes the electrical
parameter of the transistor which can be
monitored in real time
also graphing base transistors are
superior to silicon-based transistors
as graphene is biocompatible and can
directly be connected to biology without
impacting it
also biology doesn't impact graphene in
addition due to the graphene high
electron mobility this transistor can
transduce the signal
um from biological event much
much faster so our core technology
enables us to be
rapid in detection it also provides us
with quantitative analysis and not just
qualitative results the sensing part of
our platform
can be reconfigured in terms of the
analyte that can be
that we can detect ranging from dna rna
enzyme antibodies or small molecules and
in terms of form factor
that is best suited for eso specific
applications ranging from
handheld system to an automated
automated robotic systems
and all the data can be transferred
seamlessly to computers
for analysis we have been previously
developed
and published a variety of analyte
detection platforms using our
transistors in collaboration with our
academic and industrial partner this
includes the detection of zika virus in
collaboration with cdc investigators
aging by aging biomarkers based on
antibody antigen interaction in
collaboration with the university of
california berkeley
scientists small molecule detection and
cytokine detection in collaboration with
our industrial partner
our collaboration has enabled us to
further improve our technology for each
specific application
and we will continue to do so it also
enables us to work with our
collaborators and partners and combine
our expertise
to develop better products
so um so last year we have uh we
published a technology um that was using
uh um using crispr as a detection
platform
our transistor utilizes to utilize the
search function of the crispr
and we're able to seamlessly detect when
crispr molecule finds and binds to his
uh target dna uh without the need for
africa
for amplification amplification or uh
basically amplifying the target
this was the first time that an
interaction of crispr complex
with target dna sequence was captured
with an electronic transistor
the technology called crispr chip was
published last year in the cover of
nature bme and combined basically three
revolutionary
sciences transistors crispr and graphene
so after publications of the crispr chip
we have attracted many people but we're
using crispr for a variety of
applications
and uh and we're actively working on
them
we have already partnered with them or
established in partnership with them
to develop better tools to monitor the
efficacy of
of the design of crispr-based
therapeutics um
basically for various different
applications for a previous application
for gene modulation
imaging and many applications i know
technology was basically
is was used as a quality control which i
will talk about more in the next few
slides
as well as establishing partnership in
it to use our platform
for uh for amplification-free disease
detection
as well as monitoring genetic
modifications
implants
so briefly gas enzyme in our crispr
technology gas enzymes are
immobilized on the surface of the
graphene guide rnas are then introduced
to program the gas enzyme to detect the
specific dna sequences and then the dna
sample is introduced
the system can monitor the interaction
and binding of the guideline to gas
enzymes to form a stable
crispr complex in addition to monitor
the in addition it can monitor the
interaction of the crispr complex to
target dna without the need uh
for uh for amplification
we have used our crisprship technology
for a variety of different applications
detection of deletion or insertion
without amplification in human genome
we have done this in in
some genetic diseases including duchenne
muscular dystrophy disorder as well as
the
detection of single communication
without amplification in sickle cell
disease
we were able to use the technology for
comparing the efficacy of guide rnas
with different lengths
in binding to target sequences we were
able to compare the efficiency
of various different tasks uh version in
binding and targeting sequences
and the also detection of rna binding to
cast proteins in high throughput
automated system
with software package for for data
analysis
so what you see here is the result from
our previously published work which
indicated that that
which indicated the ability of crispr
chip in detection of two eggs on
deletion commonly seen in patients with
duchenne muscular dystrophy disorder
two different chips were designed one
was designed to target exon 3 and one
was designed to target exon 51 in human
dystrophin gene the ships uh
were able to detect the presence or
absence of each of these exon
in human genomic samples uh without the
need for for amplification
we have done the same thing with sickle
cell disease so we were able to detect
the
mutation mutation in hpv gene in human
genome as well without amplification
the power of real-time data is really
important for quality assurance purposes
the whole process of chip
functionalization is monitored in real
time
this was really important as we found
out about this after we developed the
technology
during the functionalization process we
first immobilized the gas enzyme and
then we introduced the guide rna
to program the cast for specific
targeting we actually monitor in real
time to ensure that the guide rna is
bound to cast enzyme as a part of our
quality assurance
it turned out that monitoring the guide
rna binding to the enzyme is very
important
as enzyme modification gas modification
environmental factors such as ph
temperature buffer
vapor composition and all of this could
impact the binding of guide rna to cast
and
stability of the complex we were able to
monitor all this event
in real time um from our uh
from our technology and from this our
our first
uh our first product was actually one
so our first product which was developed
in collaboration with coco technologies
pioneering in crispr qc
is a product to monitor the binding of
cows to guide rnas
the product utilizes an array of crispr
chips within a liquid handling system
for crisper quality control applications
the first product crispr binds monitor
the interaction between gas enzyme and
guide rna to ensure
successful complex formation and
stability in different environment
basically the system can can be used to
monitor the interaction of variety of
engineered gas enzyme
with synthetic or chemically modified
guide rnas which is a critical step
in designing effective crispr complexes
so the video that you're going to see
here shows how crispr
bind works this is of course our minimum
viable products
and the future version will be built
with features and modules that our
partner require for their specific
application
the user can select a protocol enter
information about guy
rna cast buffers and other testing
condition that they
they would like to see such as ph
temperature and evaluate the binding and
stability of the complex at this various
different conditions
the system is fully automated system
which can eliminate user variability
while providing a high throughput format
this can also provide a tool to see the
impact of different parameters
on complex stability using machine
learning and learn more about the
biology of crispr itself
okay i apologize for the silence i was
not able to talk over the video
but what you saw in the video basically
the data at the end of the
the assay that was performed by the by
the system
the data was transferred to a computer
um for analysis
and the data will be then analyzed in a
few minutes making the process
rapid and accurate without any user
variability using crispr buying product
crispr design can be optimized to
achieve the desired outcome
the plot that you can see here shows two
guide rnas with two different binding
efficiency
which were measured and analyzed with
our crisper bind
with our crisper bind the product
so the next generation of crisper
quality control prod products built on
our crisper tube technology includes
crisper amp
which monitors the efficiency of the
designed
crispr complexes to amplicons to select
the best uh
crispr complex this product will allow
you to select the best
combination of cast and guide rna and
guide rna
guide rna for maximum binding efficiency
which is very important in applications
such as crispr based gene modulation and
imaging
similar to gel electroporosis but much
easier much faster with quantitative
result in a high throughput
format future product will enable
quantitative monitoring of cleavage as
well providing us with the full picture
of crispr activity on target
on target sequences
another pipeline products uh is crispr
gen that monitors the interaction of
crispr complex with the whole genomic
sample eliminating the need for amplicon
generation and amplicon
and amplification making the whole
process significantly faster
the plots on the on the bottom right
indicates that
crispr jen can distinguish the binding
efficiency of two
guide rnas with target sequences with
single point mutation
the result the purple plots show that
the guide rna with 24 nucleotide in
length
binds less effectively the target
sequences that
have 22 nucleotides uh the results
were um were analyzed with machine
learning
and and uh and and
as you can see here the result is
comparable with the with the gel
electrophoresis resolve
but without any for amplification and by
simply just using the whole
genetic sample which significantly
reduces the time
that you require to generate those
amplicons and also the time for analysis
the next generation will also be able to
monitor cleavage activity
the product can be also utilized to
monitor the efficiency of
of gene editing before and after crispr
editing which can be
which can significantly facilitate
monitoring crispr based
editing efficiencies and we are
currently partnering with various
different industries to bring to bring
other products utilizing our
technology with that i want to thank you
for listening and please contact us if
you have any questions or if you're
interested in partnership
thank you
okay great job yeah so so what's going
to happen because i i think i
i didn't know how to i forgot that i
have to go back to these slides
yeah i know that there was a little bit
of a pause after the video but i made a
note so i can edit out the
pause and just start it again uh when
you pick back up
perfect okay thank you so much of course
any other questions for me before we
wrap up
no and thank you really for
accommodating this um
i i feel much better about this one and
i want to be sorry yeah no problem at
all and um
once we have the editing done i can send
over another preview link if you want to
take a look
thank you so much thank you have a good
rest of your day